the newest entry in the purge franchise
has arrived
if you're wondering what exactly happens
during the frightening events of the
forever purge we're here to explain the
film's ending
so let's discuss what actually happens
at the end of the forever purge before
getting into the nitty-gritty details of
what it all means
in the film's climactic battle tribal
leader thiago leads our ragtag group of
heroes across the mexican border as the
ever after perchers follow close behind
backed into a corner the good guys have
no choice but to stop running and fight
back
during the massive shootout that ensues
thiago rushes cassie and the other
survivors across as juan adella and
dylan try their best to hold off the
onslaught
minutes later perjure leader dalton
corners adella and dylan and seems to
have the upper hand
when it's nearly too late juan uses his
lasso on a final moment of bravery to
save
his wife before putting dalton down with
a bullet through his skull
the remaining heroes then make it across
the border uninjured and they're even
greeted with the news that cassie's
labor was a success and that she and
dylan have a new baby
it's a minor miracle that almost all the
main characters of the forever purge are
alive at the end with something to
celebrate
but for the rest of america we see that
the future may not be so bright
the final shot zooms out to show the
united states of america on fire
radio chatter plays it implies a
conflict saying that people are
beginning to fight back against their
aggressors
it's unclear how much time has passed
between the beginning of the forever
purge in this broadcast
but it can be assumed at least some
passage of time has occurred
the future of the u.s is left ambiguous
but the extremists who organize this
great purge are still out there and
still
killing and destroying the state of the
nation is one of civil war
an inevitable end result of the
government social experiment that began
the annual purge
by the time we're introduced to all the
protagonists of the forever purge the
plot sets off in the direction of the
border
juan and adela's current home is in
texas already so mexico isn't very far
away
but by the time they reach the border
it's heavily guarded and our heroes must
face off against the militarized purgers
in a climactic battle to fight their way
into mexico
but if safe passage is no longer viable
why go
mexico was opening its borders for the
next six hours this has a lot to do with
the characters and their deep rooted
motivations
juan and adella want to return to their
homeland across the border
driven by the fear of being in a violent
warring country that hates them they see
no choice anymore
dylan too is backed into a corner with a
pregnant wife about to go into labor he
decides to step up and be a leader
despite having no love for mexico or its
people
still it's important for them to cross
for the ending to work
that's because the final overt political
message of the forever purge is a call
for empathy
the crossing of americans into mexico is
a symbol of this theme and the ending
suggests both canada and mexico provided
enough aid to american refugees for them
to begin to recapture their fallen
country
while it was originally announced to be
the final purge movie the forever purge
might not actually be the grand finale
of the series
after all the ending definitely leaves
room for more interesting stories to be
told
it seems like series creator and
screenwriter for all the films james
demonico
is actually working on the idea for the
next purge movie even if the story is
only in the early stages
de monaco said in an ign interview if
you asked me this four months ago i
probably would have said it was the end
and then i woke up for better or worse
with a new idea three and a half months
ago and i pitched it to everyone and i
think it's another way to flip it
if the audience wants it we'll be ready
to give it but they have to tell us they
want it before we go ahead
and honestly it makes a lot of sense to
keep the story going
while critics are divided on the film
the forever purge like its predecessors
made quite a bit of cash
especially considering the series
relatively low budgets plus when you
have a series that's as political as
this one you can use it to comment on
all sorts of social issues
which means the purge movies could keep
the terror going for quite some time
the purge movie franchise has never
broken from its internal continuity
after ending the fifth film on a radio
message detailing americans fighting
back the civil war type story could be
de monaco's idea for the next film
that certainly makes more sense than if
you were to make a spin-off or break
from the established continuity of the
previous movies but you never know
a time skip can be a useful tool in
making stale franchises feel fresh again
of course the concept of the purge is so
malleable that it would be wonderful to
see the series in the hands of someone
other than demonico
the creator has remained extremely
hands-on with every property even after
giving up directorial duties following
election year
it's still a novel conceit and it would
be great to see the property in the
hands of other creators in the form of
new movies or on tv
still even if demonico continues to
guide the series it means the future is
full of fantastic and frightening
possibilities
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]